alerta naranja en Colombia los expertos
registraron Un aumento de la actividad
sísmica del volcán nevado del Ruiz en
los últimos días lo detectaron con la
fractura de rocas y con los alrededor de
11.000 sismos registrados el miércoles
los municipios aledaños activaron
medidas preventivas y el parque nacional
que alberga el volcán cerró sin embargo
el servicio geológico de Colombia aclaró
que la erupción no tendría por qué ser
inminente ese nivel naranja entonces
Vuelvo y repito no implica la erupción
inminente que ya mañana va a ocurrir
sino que ahí no probabilidad mayor no
sabemos el día ni la hora ni la fecha ni
el tamaño de esa erupción que pueda
ocurrir el Nevado del Ruiz está ubicado
en el centro de Colombia entre los
departamentos de caldas y tolima es un
estrato volcán conocido como volcán
compuesto los habitantes de la zona han
notado una mayor expulsión de ceniza
como recordarán este volcán está en un
proceso evolutivo hace unos diez años
cuando un volcán está en un proceso
eruptivo que por fortuna han sido
erupciones menores Presenta una
actividad mucho más anómala de la que ha
tenido que implica la probabilidad de
una erupción en términos de días o
semanas en 1985 el Nevado del Ruiz entró
en erupción derritió hielo y nieve
causando flujos de agua y rocas
desapareciendo prácticamente el
municipio de armero donde murieron más
de 23.000 personas fue la cuarta
catástrofe volcánica más mortal de la
historia